[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's referred to as the lonely master
in china he is jimmer for debt
he just turned 31 and he is
playing for the shanghai sharks he
scored
70 points in the game the former byu
star in fact
it was 10 years ago today jimmer that
you had 43 points
as byu beat san diego state
kawhi leonard was playing for san diego
state at the time he scored 22.
uh thanks for joining us how are you
i'm doing great dan thanks for having me
on i appreciate it and yes those were
those were great memories 10 years ago
that's for sure what do you remember
about kawhi leonard back then
i mean the thing about kawhi is like uh
you know he was only there for two years
but you know i played him those two
years and he and from his freshman year
to his sophomore year you could tell he
got substantially better
um especially offensively he was always
gifted athletically
um rebounded extremely well you know
that was one of the big things to try to
keep him off the glass but he could just
play
defense he was he affected the game in
so many different ways
but then sophomore year he started
shooting you know a little bit more
from mid-range and from the three-point
area um
you know just got a little bit better
offensively and then obviously as he got
into the nba
um you know he's just you know blown
blown up he's played unbelievable
basketball
so you scored 70 a couple of days ago
did you score
70 on purpose
um no not really i definitely just
wanted to go out there and just be
aggressive
did you know my game it just but did you
know you had seven one of those games
did you know you were like hey you got
64. you got uh you can get 70. okay
um i definitely knew what my point total
was because i mean the scoreboard is
right there you can see your points
uh you know throughout the whole game so
obviously you're aware of what's going
on
um but at the end of the game you know i
just i got a steal at the end of the
game
and it was just kind of one of those
things where i was at 68 and i got an
easy steal and was able to go in and
you know make it for the 70th point um
you know so
i wasn't planning on it but uh you know
it happened and
uh you know it was a fun night for sure
have you ever scored 70 before in a game
actually i have so this is actually my
uh this is my third time
scoring over 70 in the cba
so i've scored 75 73 and then this is my
70.
so i've done it three times the only
player would ever do it in the cba i
guess so
uh the the talent that you're playing
against is comparable to what
um you know these guys are they're good
players i mean they're good
good professional basketball players i
mean it's it's not
you know european uh euro league level
um
you know but they're you know they're
really good players they're they're
strong athletic guys
um several of these chinese guys have
played um you know have had some a
little bit of stints in the nba or in
the g
league or in some of those things um you
know obviously but
they're they're they're high level
players but what they are is they're
strong
and they're physical especially on the
defensive end i mean they're
they come after you know the americans
every single night
they don't want you to score the
basketball they'll double triple team
you they'll follow you
you know they'll push you to do
everything they can to get in your under
your skin and in your head
so it's definitely not not easy um on a
nightly basis
but we have the ball in our hands so
much that sometimes you're able to just
you know have a great game and just
start feeling it
how concerned were you you know here you
are married you got two kids you're
going to china you got covid
uh you know the hong kong situation with
the nba
with daryl murray's comments like was
there any trepidation about going back
to china
um for me obviously uh you know during
this period of of coba that was you know
the biggest concern
um for us um you know but we we knew
coming over here that we were probably
gonna be in a bubble for the whole
season and we have been
um so as long as we were able to get the
visa that was
probably the hardest thing to do was to
actually get the visa to be able to come
over
to play um but i knew that i was going
to be over here for a long period of
time without my family so that's by far
the hardest thing
i haven't been able to see him for four
months and uh you know
we'll play another two months over here
at least until we go back home so i mean
i have two young ones and that's no
that's not easy
but uh it's a sacrifice you make
sometimes as an overseed basketball
player
so i'm blessed to be able to be able to
have an opportunity to play still and
make money and be able to provide for my
family so you have to look at it that
way sometimes but if you weren't playing
in china
what would you be doing where would you
be playing
i'd probably be playing in the euro
league still um you know i was with uh
with ponte the nikos in greece last year
which was a great experience i love
athens
um really really awesome to be able to
go around europe and see all the cool
cities in europe and be able to play
against some great
basketball teams and basketball players
but i had a second year option to go
back to greece
but we decided not to and this
opportunity with shanghai came back up
and decided to take this one and uh you
know it's been it's been fun
the uh jimmer fredette family
foundation's mission
is to spread kindness and uh strengthen
families
so they can raise children with strong
moral character
and uh they come to the aid of youth who
are hungry
cold bullied or afraid it's the ferdet
family
foundation your first nba game i believe
was against kobe bryant
yes yes it was um you know obviously
this is the year anniversary of his
his passing and that was so tragic i
remember you know last year when we were
in greece my wife and i were
sitting on the couch and we got the news
um and it was just absolutely
devastating
for everybody involved not you know with
kobe's family but also the other
families that were involved in the
helicopter crash but um you know my
first game
i walked in i subbed into the game and
we were playing against the lakers i was
with the sacramento king so it was a
little rivalry
everyone was amped up and i walk in and
of course you know the first person that
guards me is kobe bryant
and uh he he walks right up to me he
just puts he puts his uh you know
forearm right into my chest and just
says
welcome to the nba and i was like all
right here we go
me versus kobe so it was uh
it was a welcome to the nba moment for
sure how did you do
i think i was scared to take the first
couple of shots i think he was
like stepping back and giving me those
shots too he was like i didn't know
you know almost daring me to shoot it
and that's what i was do that's what i
do you know but
you know your first nba game you're just
like you don't know exactly what's going
on you're just trying to figure it all
out
and as i got into the game i got a
little bit better but those first couple
of possessions were
were definitely something that uh that i
remember we asked this every time you
had we have you on
why aren't you on an nba roster
yeah i mean um i'm sure it's a mixture
of a lot of different reasons
you know obviously but uh at this point
um
you know i've i've had a couple of
chances in the nba and
um some places have been better than
others but ultimately
um you know my path has led me over to
to shanghai and playing in europe and
playing in china
it's more more more recently and you
know it's been
it's been a great opportunity and
situation for me
so honestly uh you know i'm grateful and
happy for the situation that i've been
able to find over here
been able to succeed and do really well
make a name for myself over here not
only just in china but back
back in the us people are still you know
seeing the highlights and seeing how i'm
doing which has been
really really great to be able to do um
you know uh the nba has been a
it was a great opportunity for me but
you know it didn't work out necessarily
exactly
how i thought it would or many people
thought it would but uh it hasn't
stopped me from continuing to play at a
high level of basketball
but would you rather be the man in china
or a bench player in the nba
it all for me it depends on the
situation like if i was a bench player
that was coming in and
and playing you know there i was allowed
to play my game and was you know playing
20 minutes a game and
and able to be a really uh integral part
of a team
then i would love to be able to do that
i know obviously i'd love to be a
be able to compete against the best in
the world and be able to make an impact
on a team like that
but uh being here in china and being
able to have the impact that i've had
not just on the court but off the court
has been has been something that's been
special
um you know so i'd rather be doing that
than necessarily just sitting on an nba
bench just to sit there
i think it's been better for my career
and better for the impact
is your nickname the lonely master
yeah it's the lonely master so it's it's
uh gmo dashin
is what it's called and gmo means lonely
and it sounds like jimmer gmo and that's
how people kind of pronounce my name
over here they can't really
pronounce the er so they say gmo gmo and
it means lonely and then they put dash
in at the end which means actually
god i guess and then we changed it kind
of to lonely master
so i i didn't want to be known as a god
so i just said
let's do the lonely master but it's but
is it lonely so lonely is based on how
they pronounce your name
they don't they don't think you're
lonely they just
i mean you are sort of lonely yeah
yeah it was kind of a double meaning for
it what they told me what i would you
know the interpretation from what my
teammates told me
uh the fans said that you know gmo
obviously you're alone you're kind of
over here by yourself you're not with
your family for one thing but also it
kind of means like
you're kind of on the top of the
mountain and no one can kind of reach
your level
you know what i mean so they're kind of
saying like it's it's lonely on the top
and that's kind of the double meaning
for it and
my first year that i got here i got that
that nickname
and we had a great season was mvp at the
seat of the year so it kind of just
stuck i guess
are they going to build a statue does
doesn't stephan marbury have a statue
over there jimmer
yeah he does he he does outside of the
beijing arena
um i don't know if i'm at that level i
mean he uh he's
you know the biggest thing that has been
over here and his team won three
championships while he was there in
beijing and they hadn't won for a long
time so
we haven't won any championships yet
maybe if we get one uh
we'll see but uh yeah he's he's got the
statue out in front of the beijing arena
could you give me a hundred
in a game over there
[Laughter]
maybe we'll see it's gonna have to go
into like four or five overtimes
probably but
but uh you know i'll try for you i'll
try but you get the green light right
you can shoot whenever you want to
yes right you definitely get the you
definitely get the green light
they want you to score like they bring
you over here specifically to score the
basketball
you know like that's what they're
looking for the giant you know the
chinese players
expect that from you you have the ball
in your hands um
you know if you're a scorer they want
you to score if you're a guy that's
if you're a big guy you know they want
you to get 20 rebounds a game you know
five blocks you know that type of thing
they bring you over here for a reason
um you know obviously you don't score
you know 70 points every night but
every once in a while you're able to to
feel good and i you know i felt good
last night and was able to make
make shots and you don't want to play
any defense right
only on certain occasions of course this
is just like byu
you don't have to play any defense and
you get to shoot you got the green light
jimmer
hey you can you can do whatever you want
you gotta you gotta stick to your lane
do what you're good
do what you're good at right what is
behind you
like is that your apartment
uh so so i'm in a hotel in my hotel room
right now
okay and uh we're in juji china
and uh so i've been in this hotel room
for four months so this has been what
i've been seeing for the last four
months just kind of this curtain behind
me and
this small little room that we're in so
yeah it's definitely interesting is
there like a buffalo wild wings over
there or a jersey mike
sub or yeah like is there anything that
reminds you
i mean in this city no so it's funny
because you know this city is considered
a small city in china
but there's seven million people here
and uh that's just kind of what they
consider
a small city and uh you know so
but the thing is we can't actually leave
the bubble so i've been
you know we've been in the the hotel and
they have you know a buffet that's
prepared for us every day and basically
my meal is uh
you know i get a salad with some white
rice and chicken breast every day and
that's what i've been eating for last
four months so i feel like i'm on a
bodybuilding diet
so i feel healthy and feel good um but
uh
yeah not anything of normalcy at this
point but uh hopefully when i get back
to shanghai
that i'll be able to to get some stuff
uh lonely master
he's the lonely master joining us uh
from china
hey congrats jimmer and uh i hope you
get a chance to see your family here
soon and good luck over there and
you know next time you go over 70 we'll
have you back on again
sounds good dan i appreciate it thank
you love the show thank you buddy that's
uh jimmy fardet
joining us from somewhere in china
shanghai sharks point guard